l'avocate Émilie tente Gisèle à minimi
se plaignait de la malédiction de notre
fille à une époque où le patriarcat
ayant maître vous je l'ai mis une kowski
vous êtes une enfant des années 80
pourtant il n'était pas rare d'entendre
déjà à cette époque là que le pénal
n'est pas un métier de femme dans une
salle d'audience est-ce qu'il vous est
arrivé d'éprouver cette sensation d'être
né du mauvais côté
à votre sourire je sens que la réponse
est oui
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on disait à
l'époque des j'étais à la limite
finalement elle on lui laissait de la
place parce que bah il fallait bien
qu'il y ait un contre-exemple une femme
avocate connue du grand public et puis
elle s'occupait d'affaires de bonne fans
finalement elle s'occupait de la
question d'avortement elle s'occupait du
viol donc voilà laisser être militante
féministe dans les prétoirs or des
paillettes de justice mais apparaît on
ne parlait jamais jamais d'aucune femme
moi j'ai mis un peu de temps à le
comprendre parce que j'ai pas du tout
été élevé avec l'idée qui aurait des
métiers pour les hommes et des métiers
pour les femmes je voulais être avocat
pénaliste à me paraissait être le plus
le plus beau métier du monde j'ai eu la
chance en plus d'être recruté tout de
suite par un formidable mentor en
apportant de l'Hervé Times mais au bout
de quelques temps j'ai observé qu'autour
de moi les ténors étaient des hommes les
collaboratrices étaient des femmes que
quand on parlait de toute la mythologie
autour du barreau il n'était jamais
question
d'aucune femme
et que quand j'avais un dossier
personnel comme on dit c'est à dire
qu'il n'était pas un dossier du cabinet
qui était indocia à moi et que je
m'approchais à la barre le président ne
savait pas très bien si c'était bien mon
dossier ou si j'étais là pour substituer
quelqu'un d'autre diriez-vous que vous
avez eu du mal à trouver votre place au
pénal
alors moi paradoxalement je m'occupe
depuis un certain temps d'essayer de
faire valoir la qualité des femmes
d'avocats de pénalistes mais j'estime
avoir eu personnellement beaucoup de
chance parce que j'ai rencontré RVT mime
complètement par hasard qui m'a donné ma
chance comme stagiaire comme
collaboratrice puis comme associé très
jeune il m'a laissé plaider à ses côtés
dans des dossiers très importants là où
la plupart des patrons demandent à leur
collaboratrice qui a étudié tout le
dossier classé fait des cotes des
kilomètres de papier imprimés de
s'éclipser au moment du procès deux
éclipser ou en tout cas de les regarder
avec des grands yeux plaider donc
je pense que contrairement à d'autres
j'ai eu moins de moins de difficultés
mais comment expliquer vous cause la
robe c'est mieux aux hommes votre
console Frédéric Beaulieu regrette je la
cite que les prétoirs sont un lieu de
promotion des valeurs virils et
guerrières et le pénal un monde d’ego
Bours
non mais en fait on entend mieux quand
même avec un micro donc s'il vous plaît
mettre donc il y a toute une façon
nouvelle de plaider à laquelle il faut
que tout le monde s'adapte et c'est pour
ça que je pense que les femmes là ont
tiennent peut-être enfin la chance de de
de s'imposer beaucoup mieux est-ce que
c'est parce que vous en aviez marre
d'entendre qu'une femme n'a pas les
épaules pour être pénaliste que vous
avez fondé en 2013 le club des femmes
pénalistes et co-écrit en 2021 ce livre
avec la journaliste Liza Vignoli
l'avocat était une femme qu'est-ce qui
vous a concrètement poussé à vous
engager au côté des femmes quel en était
l'élément déclencheur parce que votre
engagement d'avant le mouvement MiTo oui
bah l'élément déclencheur c'est des des
propos bien malheureux tenus par un
avocat bordelais
à une époque où se tenait les élections
ordinales c'est-à-dire l'élection du
bâtonnier de Bordeaux et une femme avait
de l'autre cuit danse selon lui de se
présenter et il était intervenu à la à
la télévision sur France Télé je me
souviens pour dire mais enfin une femme
bâtonnier mais ça n'existe pas vous avez
déjà vu par exemple une femme pénaliste
mais il y a pas d'avocats pénaliste
enfin elles n'ont pas les elles n'ont
pas les épaules elles sont beaucoup trop
sensibles enfin tous les clichés
possible et imaginables y étaient passé
et ça nous avait vraiment
heurté et d'autant que cet épisode
venait juste après une photo qui avait
été publiée dans le magazine Paris Match
je me souviens très bien l'orchestre du
barreau de Paris avec que des hommes que
des femmes une femme assise au milieu
qui a justement été la première
bâtonnière de Paris comme c'était dans
la bibliothèque de l'ordre des avocats
je pense que on s'était quand même senti
obligé de l'inviter et voilà le
franchement de de ces deux épisodes
m'a vraiment mené à à conduire cette
réflexion avec des consœurs
en premier lieu Rachel Lindon avec qui
je déjeunais et on a d'abord c'est
d'abord dit on va écrire une tribune
et qui s'intitulait une femme pénaliste
ça n'existe pas et pourquoi pas en écho
à la fameuse comptine voilà
et j'ai rencontré après ça Véronique
Morali qui
a été l'inspiratrice de nombreux de
nombreuses associations de
professionnels de femmes
qui m'a dit mais enfin pourquoi est-ce
que tu ne fais pas ça pour les femmes
avocats alors justement à quoi ça sert à
quoi sert ce club concrètement
ce club déjà en premier lieu c'était une
réponse à notre tribune
s'il y a un club des femmes pénalistes
elles existent
de dire elles sont là alors je vous
cache pas qu'on a été parfois moqué
critiqué mais enfin qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce truc de base de bonne femme etc
mais c'était d'abord ça c'était un
espace de sororité pour reprendre un mot
de la mode mais auquel était attaché je
vis à la limite il y a un mot qui est
pas très agréable à l'oreille qui est
pas très jolie mais qui veut dire
quelque chose qui veut dire quelque
chose selon moi de très fort
c'est donc un lieu d'échange
soutien aussi j'imagine
d'entraide s'envoyer des dossiers
alors au fil du temps il y a des années
on n'a pas fait grand chose et puis
maintenant on essaye vraiment
d'organiser régulièrement des apéros on
se retrouve tout ensemble en fait c'est
très amical et convivial et puis on fait
un événement incoloc sur des sujets qui
nous paraissent être à la fois du pénal
et pouvant concerner les femmes comme la
présomption d'innocence à l'épreuve de
demi-tour ou la condition des femmes en
prison et de faire venir toute sorte des
intervenants on essaie de faire en sorte
que un homme quand même les intervenants
parce qu'on n'est pas sectaires mais
voilà depuis l'apparition de l'avocate
est une femme les dupont-moretta
sont-elles enfin sorties de l'ombre car
j'imagine que la presse a aussi sa part
de responsabilité dans
l'invisibilisation des avocats
j'adore cette expression de
dupont-moretta qui m'a été soufflée par
l'avocate Cécile des Oliveira c'est vrai
que le fait qu'Eric Dupond-Moretti soit
garde des sceaux par rapport à l'image
de l'avocat pénaliste ça n'aide pas les
femmes parce que il incarne absolument
cette image du Nord dont on parlait tout
à l'heure qui gronde enfin vraiment il a
toutes les caractéristiques
les dupont-moretta elle commence à
sortir de l'ombre
je j'espère avoir apporté ma pierre à
l'édifice avec la création du club avec
le livre ce qui est certain c'est que
pour revenir à elle mais c'est important
je pense de le dire donc Pascal
robertder la chronique que judiciaire du
monde explique que notre livre la
moquette est une femme a vraiment été un
déclencheur pour elle
pour comprendre à quel point elle avait
sa part de responsabilité dans cette
visibilisation des femmes puisque il lui
arrivait fréquemment quand elle
chronique est un procès de ne pas faire
mention des avocats qui intervenaient de
ne pas se rendre compte que justement
derrière cette éloquence
traditionnel il y avait autre chose il y
avait un travail toujours très précis
très minutieux des femmes une façon de
plaider sans doute plus apaisée que
celle des hommes qui marquaient au fur
et à mesure sont son efficacité après
c'est presque dangereux en fait de
d'essayer de Serrier les
caractéristiques des femmes quand elles
plate puisque un contre cliché mais je
disais la limite disait qu'une femme ne
plaît pas de la même façon qu'un homme
que son expérience de la discrimination
était une force
si vous confirmez je confirme totalement
[Musique]
quand on enfile la robe il n'est plus
question de genre en revanche nous
sommes nous venons tous avec une
histoire avec une histoire personnelle
mais aussi avec une histoire collective
des gens qui nous ressemblent donc moi
je suis entièrement d'accord avec ce
qu'elle dit évidemment que quand
soi-même on a subi des discriminations
quand soi-même dans le prétoire on sent
qu'on doit faire davantage encore ses
preuves et que l'on défend des gens qui
sont poursuivis qui sont accusés
ça nous donne quelque chose je sais pas
si c'est quelque chose en plus tu payes
c'est quelque chose en moi mais en tout
cas c'est quelque chose de différent que
les hommes ne peuvent pas expérimenter
les femmes les ténorrents auraient un
supplément d'âme par rapport à leurs
homologues masculins elles font passer
dit-elle la personne l'humain avant les
actes qu'il ou elle a pu commettre
je pense que si un homme avocat
entendait ça ils bondirait horrifié
parce que
ce que les femmes peuvent apporter sans
tomber dans le contre-cliché qui revient
à dire ben oui alors toutes les femmes
justement sont plus sérieuses sont plus
conscieuses je travaille plus même si
c'est quand même d'expérience moi ce que
je peux constater la plupart du temps
elles ont été obligées en tout cas de
réinventer la façon de plaider puisque
très peu d'entre elles pouvaient
concurrencer les hommes sur le coffre
sur l'organe donc elles ont cherché et
moi je me souviens très bien par exemple
avoir entendu plaider une avocat de
pénaliste qui n'exerce plus qui
s'appelle Françoise cotta et alors elle
elle s'approchait de du tribunal elle
murmurait elle chuchotait presque et
elle racontait une histoire absolument
et c'était différent de tout ce que
j'avais entendu auparavant je me suis
dit mais bon sang finalement il y a
plein d'autres façons de faire parce que
après tout et ça c'est RVT mime mon
associé mentor qui me l'a qui me l'a
appris l'efficacité du plaidoirie elle
ne se mesure pas à l'éloquence de
l'avocat c'est pas la plaidoirie à la
fin de laquelle vous avez envie
d'applaudir en disant oh là là
magnifique magnifique non c'est la
plaidoirie à la fin de laquelle vous
dites
c'est lui c'est elle qui a raison quel
est votre pâte je termine
votre marque de fabrique
si vous devez
[Musique]
ce que j'essaye de faire en tout cas
c'est de
me défaire justement d'un ton qui
pourrait être trop éloigné de la façon
dont je défendrai la personne le dossier
dans la vie je pense qu'il faut faire
très attention quand on est avocat à ne
pas avoir le syndrome ça c'est plus un
mot de de communiquant on vous dit si
vous allez à télécs il faut pas avoir le
syndrome Péron de l'Elysée c'est à dire
tout à coup j'en filme ma façon de
parler extrêmement
réfléchi poussé je crois que si on veut
montrer ça sincérité il faut essayer de
s'abstraire en fait de de la parole de
tout l'apparade du stress personnel
qu'on peut évidemment ressentir du trac
en réalité pour avoir une conversation
les yeux dans les yeux avec les
magistrats encore plus quand vous êtes à
la cour d'assises ou vous parlez à des
vous parlez à des jurés
je pense que c'est
la raison pour laquelle en tout cas je
n'écris pas mes plaidoiries voilà
j'écris premier paragraphe le dernier
parce que il faut quand même avoir c'est
comme des béquilles en fait pour moi
quelque chose à quoi se raccrocher quand
on commence parce que là le trac est au
plus fort et puis parfois on a du mal à
terminer aussi donc voilà on a la bonne
vision la conclusion mais entre les deux
si vous écrivez vous ne pouvez pas avoir
ce naturel donc moi j'espère que ma pâte
c'est le naturel
Hervé thémin dont vous dont vous parliez
qui votre mentor affirme que s'il avait
besoin d'un avocat il prendrait une
femme quel intérêt y a-t-il pour un
homme à être défendu par une femme il
semblerait qu'il en est un aujourd'hui
notamment dans les affaires de
caractères sexuels
oui
c'est tout à fait vrai
l'avantage quand on est une femme dans
les affaires à caractère sexuel
c'est que déjà on n'a pas cette crainte
d'être taxée de misogynie alors on sait
qu'il y a des femmes qui n'aiment pas
les femmes etc mais enfin la priori
n'est pas le même donc déjà quand on
prend la parole puisque encore une fois
on parle doux d'où l'on vient pour
soi-même mais y compris dans les yeux
des autres quand on prend la parole on
est beaucoup plus libre de ses propos
les victimes d'agression sexuelle sont
la plupart du temps pas toujours mais on
parle la plupart du temps des femmes
donc c'est vrai que il y a très
certainement une façon d'aborder les
choses d'interroger par exemple une
victime dont on estime qu'elle a menti
parce que ça existe interroger une femme
dans ce contexte là quand vous êtes
vous-même une femme évidemment que c'est
beaucoup moins délicat que quand on est
un homme
auquel on va on va toujours répondre
seconde enfin vous êtes un homme vous ne
pouvez pas comprendre voilà il y a une
une liberté dans la défense des des
personnes poursuivies pour les
infractions à caractère sexuel que les
hommes certainement n'ont pas mais alors
que répondez-vous à cette et ceux qui
voient justement un paradoxe à portée
des combats féministes et en même temps
à défendre des hommes accusés de crimes
sexuels ou de féminicides il y a un
conflit de loyauté parfois
notre combat féministe et notre
attachement à la présomption d'innocence
à cette certitude que toute personne a
droit à une à une défense mais je
voudrais pas faire des des parallèles
qui pourraient heurter mais enfin dans
ces cas là il y a tout un tas de
personnes qui du fait de leur genre mais
aussi de leur religion de leur
engagements politiques qui seraient
empêchés de défendre telle ou telle vous
vous trahissez totalement votre serment
en fait si vous vous positionnez comme
ça donc moi je suis intimement
convaincue qu'on peut être féministe et
des formes un homme qui est poursuivi
pour des infractions à caractère sexuel
c'est notre métier et la présomption
d'innocence on y est attaché alors ça
c'est très compliqué c'est vrai pour les
avocats de pénalistes ce conflit entre
me too et la présomption d'instance
puisque
#nemi tous c'est justement beaucoup
il faut libérer la parole bien avant
qu'il y a un procès et bien avant qu'une
personne était retenue coupable donc là
vraiment on est sur des sujets on marche
vraiment sur un fil et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que au sein même des
avocats de pénalistes et du club des
femmes pénalistes justement les
adhérents il y a des débats comment
expliquer que si peu de plaintes pour
viol aboutissent à une condamnation
en tant que femme ça vous révolte
c'est un sujet extrêmement délicat
déjà aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup plus de
femmes qui
osent franchir la plante du commissariat
je pense qu'il faut s'en réjouir ce qui
était vraiment scandalé pendant des
années c'était le traitement déjà des
plaintes et des femmes qui étaient
raccompagnées à la porte
aujourd'hui encore j'ai des clients
quand elles vont porter plainte
auxquelles on pose des questions d'un
autre descendant mais pourquoi lui
avez-vous ouvert la porte ce soir là si
vous n'aviez pas l'intention de d'avoir
une relation sexuelle avec lui enfin bon
[Musique]
après la difficulté évidemment qu'on a
assez une difficulté c'est une
difficulté probatoire comme tout
infraction qui se déroule entre quatre
murs avec deux personnes
et moi ce que je pense c'est qu'il faut
vraiment éduquer c'est-à-dire que
libérer la parole c'est c'était la
première étape maintenant il faut
éduquer les jeunes filles il faut
éduquer les femmes parce que ça peut
évidemment arriver à tout âge qu'est-ce
que vous devez faire si vous êtes
victime de ce type d'infraction
qu'est-ce que l'entourage doit faire il
faut conserver le maximum de preuves
donc il faut pas se doucher il faut pas
mettre ses affaires à laver il faut tout
de suite en parler laisser des traces
envoyer des SMS des emails si on n'a pas
le courage d'aller tout de suite porter
plainte mais pour montrer que tout de
suite vous en avez parlé pour
retenir les heures les échanges que vous
avez pu peut-être avoir avec votre
agresseur il faut vraiment réagir tout
de suite pour
éviter de se confronter à ce problème de
la preuve qui bien souvent mène
justement à un non-lieu à une relax à un
acquittement qui n'aurait pas dû se
produire et parce qu'on peut pas
demander au magistrats de ne se fonder
que sur la parole parce que vous avez
suivi et vous avez défendu pardon un
homme poursuivi pour viol il a été
condamné cinq ans après les faits et
incarcérés ça vous a rendu malade
alors oui voilà je
vois à quoi vous faites référence parce
que
pourquoi alors
oui ça n'avait rien à voir avec
[Musique]
l'infraction pour laquelle il était il
était poursuivi qui effectivement était
un viol c'était une affaire très
particulière entre
deux jeunes gens qui n'avaient jamais eu
de relation sexuelle elle avait 18 ans
moins deux semaines et lui avait 18 ans
plus un mois
ce qui m'a rendu malade c'est pas qu'il
soit condamné c'est la façon dont
l'audience s'est déroulée c'est à dire
que c'est une audience dans laquelle je
n'ai à aucun moment réussi à faire
valoir la parole de la défense
à tel point que dans les semaines qui
s'en sont en suivi ma voix s'est
retrouvé totalement voilée j'avais eu
exactement
j'avais eu le sentiment de ne ne pas
être entendu pendant les débats la
présidente vous voyez comme quoi on
parlait tout à l'heure des magistrats
mais des femmes mais la présidente me
rabrouillait en permanence je n'avais
jamais le droit d'intervenir pour rien
elle les les témoins achats avaient
toujours le temps de tout expliquer
quand ceux qui étaient à des charges
étaient balayé d'un reversement mais ça
c'est l'injustice qu'on
connaît tous les jours j'ai parfois des
audiences qui au contraire se passe très
bien et même parfois par des mauvais
résultats mais où je sais que la parole
de la défense a été entendue entendu pas
forcément compris mais où on nous a
permis de nous exprimer et là ça n'avait
pas été le cas l'époque j'aime une
copski n'est pas au droit à l'oubli
Bertrand Cantat chantait alors le vent
l'emportera pour lui rien n'était passé
il a pourtant été condamné pour violence
volontaire ayant entraîné la mort sans
intention de la donner il a purgé sa
peine il a donc payé sa dette à la
société pour autant
ni se produire ni apparaître dans la
presse sans susciter une vague
d'indignation une protestation qu'est-ce
que cela vous inspire en tant que femme
et bien sûr en tant qu'avocat
vous savez cette chanson qui
symbolise justement
l'oubli j'ai été une fois invité à une
émission pour parler de mon métier etc
puis on m'avait dit de demander de
choisir une chanson j'avais demandé
cette chanson là et je m'étais posé la
question de savoir s'ils allaient
m'écouter il y avait l'air d'avoir aucun
problème et vraiment juste avant que
l'antenne s'ouvre quelqu'un venu voir en
me disant on a gardé votre chanson mais
on a pris une version chantée par une
femme qui est d'ailleurs est très jolie
version elle dit mais pourquoi moi j'ai
demandé la chanson et finalement ils
l'ont passé mais voilà quand même
jusqu'où ça va c'est à dire que de
passer une chanson du passé
[Musique]
dans le livre l'avocat était une femme
avec les avignoli nous avons donné la
parole assez insec qui a été l'avocat de
Bertrand Cantat
la société aujourd'hui
et hier peut-être aussi en vérité
et David de condamnation
avant les exécutions étaient en place
publique n'ont pas l'oublier dans les
médias la peine de mort n'est pas
d'abolie sur les réseaux sociaux on le
voit là sur un une infraction
particulièrement dramatique avec un
décès mais c'est pareil si vous pensez
par exemple aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il
peut se passer dans le monde politique
par exemple une personne qui a commis
une infraction et bannie à tout jamais
de la sphère de la sphère publique les
morts socialement et on voudrait qu'il
ne puisse exercer plus aucun métier je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup de pédagogie à
avoir déjà il faut apprendre ce qu'est
la prévention d'innocence parce que ça
permettra aussi à la presse de
travailler on peut pas mettre toute la
responsabilité sur les journalistes non
plus donc si les gens savent qu'une
personne est présumée innocente quand on
parlera d'une affaire ça aura moins de
répercussions sur la personne et puis je
crois qu'il y a une réflexion à mener
si ce n'est sur le pardon en tout cas
sur en tout cas sur l'oubli il y a des
personnes qui ont un métier qui ne
savent pas en faire d'autres et on peut
pas les interdire toute leur vie de de
l'exercer mais c'est compliqué parce que
si vous mettez du côté des des victimes
et partie civils ça vous est
insupportable
d'imaginer que qu'une personne qui a
entraîné la mort de quelqu'un puisse
continuer à mener la sienne là où votre
proche de l'arthroa jamais j'aimerais
revenir sur les femmes avocates style
delivera autre avocate votre console
pronostic que les grands avocats du 21e
siècle seront des avocats de vous
confirmer ce siècle sera celui des
femmes dans les prêts de poids
en tout cas je l'espère mon grand-père
qui n'était pas d'avocat mais qui était
médecin le professeur Alexandre
linkowski
à la fin de sa vie me disait tous les
jours
quand les femmes prendront le pouvoir le
monde tournera bien plus rond
donc je pense qu'on ne peut appeler de
nos vœux que
évidemment la victoire des ténorah sur
les ténors et puis c'est comme c'est
comme tous les combats c'est à dire que
ça n'aura qu'un temps l'idéal évidemment
c'est c'est l'égalité c'est que tout le
monde est la même chose de réussir merci
Julia merci Daphné